يوم القيامة،
لم يعد الاسم الوحيد لنهاية العالم،
بل أصبح يطلق على الطائرة الأعظم في العالم.....
على الأرض يمتلك الرئيس الأمريكي
أقوى سيارة مدرعة في العالم،
والتي تدعى بالثكنة العسكرية،
لكن ماذا عن الجو،
هنا  يتبادر إلى الذهن السؤال التالي.
ما هو مصير قائد أقوى الدول في العالم،
في حال نشوب حرب نووية؟
،  حيث يستحيل قيادة الدولة على الأرض حينها؟
فما هو الحل عندها؟
يأتي حل هذه المشكلة بالنسبة لأقوى دولتين في العالم
أمريكا وروسيا،، بطائرة أطلق عليها
(طائرة يوم القيامة)،،
وصُنعت هذه الطائرة بمواصفات عالية ونادرة
خصيصا لرئيسي أمريكا وروسيا  كلا على حدة،
مع كبار الضباط الذين سيقومون بحمايتهما
وقيادة الطائرات في حال الهروب من أي هجوم نووي محتمل.
لكن ما الذي يجعل طائرة يوم القيامة مميزة إلى هذه الدرجة؟
قبل ذلك يكفي أن نعلم أن ثمن هذه الطائرة
يبلغ 223 مليون دولار أمريكي.
فلماذا هي باهظة الثمن هكذا؟
والإجابة ملخصة في مواصفات الطائرة،،
• فهي تحلق لمدة سبعة أيام بشكل مستمر دون توقف.
• ويمكن لطاقم القيادة ومن على متنها، التواصل مع الأرض
في أي بقعة من العالم أثناء تحليقها في الجو.
• بينما تتفوق قوتها على أسطول قوات الدفاع الجوي الأمريكي .
•  كما أنها صممت بطريقة تجعلها محصنة ضد الهجوم النووي
والنيازك والشهب وأي قوة جوية أخرى.
• ويعمل محركها 24 ساعة في اليوم،
ل 365 يوم في العام،
أي أنها لا تتوقف عن العمل وهي جاهزة للإقلاع
في أي لحظة إذا ما دعت الحاجة بشكل طارئ.
• الدولة الوحيدة التي تمتلك مثل هذه الطائرة بعد الولايات المتحدة
هي روسيا.
هذه الطائرة مزودة بوسائل حماية إشعاعية،
تستطيع أن تقلع.  في  غضون دقائق فقط من حدوث الهجوم.
• وتتكون من ثلاثة طوابق وتحتوي على أجهزة متطورة للغاية
تجعلها أكثر تحملا للنبضات الكهرومغناطيسية.
• وبينما يستطيع الضابط القائد للطائرة معرفة أماكن وجود الرئيس الأمريكي
ونائبه و وزير الدفاع والخارجية والنائب العام
عبر الشاشات داخل الطائرة. حتى أنها تستطيع
أرسال الأوامر إلى الغواصات العسكرية
المختبئة في أعماق المحيطات في أي بقعة من المحيط.
بطائرة يوم القيامة وبسيارة الشبح الأمريكية
تحاول القيادة
تجنب أي حادث أو حرب مفاجئة
فهل يكفي هذا لينجو القادة الأمريكان من قدرهم المحتوم يوما ما؟